[Music]
okay here's how it works we find a video
online a real video that has under 100
views really struggling then we add a
celebrity and repost the video boom
instant viral hit or at least another
100 views anyway I was checking the web
and I found this video of a girl tap
dancing that only has 89 views
it's called tap dance number 98 ok
Google show me YouTube plays you get the
idea okay well why isn't that burning up
the Internet yeah no no mystery as to
why they got 89 views alright
so we added a celebrity to the mix to
help turn that clip into a viral hit
roll it
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll kill myself in five six seven eight
[Music]
Big Finish
[Applause]
and by the way we're having a contest
this related to this where you can win
my phone literally this is my phone the
one I'm holding right here
you can win it okay and it's got all my
private information right I'm not
kidding I don't care I don't you know
Norm Macdonald beeper is on there yeah
Oh was that you got a lot of big stars
in there I got Google searches in here
Oh selfies selfies boudoir selfies
anyway just send us a clip and if we use
it for our next celebrity video boost
this baby right here my phone is yours
just go to team koco.com slash video
boost to learn more
[Applause]